I knew my music was always this big part
of the community of dance I love making
incredible music for them to dance to
Dancing with the Stars is set to take on
Michael Buble as next week's theme for
its 31st season and of course everyone
is excited from regular Canadians to the
contestants to Buble himself who
actually teamed up with this pal Derek
Huff to bring Buble weak to life I was
like what about a Dancing With the Stars
week and he was like that sounds great
he's the one that ended up taking it to
the to the producers and and we sort of
did it together
my bubbles I love him I'm choreographing
a big piece uh next week uh he's gonna
be performing singing and I'll be
dancing in it as well it's gonna be
great to celebrate him and his music but
of course everybody every that night and
we can't wait but of course we're not
the only ones who are excited to
experience Michael Buble on Dancing With
the Stars as the cast themselves are big
Buble fans as well I'm so excited I grew
up a huge Michael Buble fan I love all
his songs I can like just list easy
listening in the car so it's just
different like I'm learning with dance
like when you actually like the music in
the song it like brings out a different
side of you so I'm excited about that
one yeah
Michael Buble that voice just soft
sultry fabulous but his music is a
really beautiful soundtrack to This Not
Just genre of movement then ballroom
dancing but also this space I mean this
is a perfect space to host Michael Buble
in his music now of course it's going to
be cool to see everyone dance along to
our Canadian icon but dare I say that
the bigger draw is to see the Bromance
between Michael and Derek you know it's
one of those things where you when you
meet somebody and you just five you just
gel you just get each other and that
sounds kind of silly but we met and it
was just nothing but love constantly and
um he's just a real genuine great man
who just happens to be extraordinarily
talented
um and just an icon
foreign
[Music]